Apple's budget iPhone se4 is coming and
it is going to destroy the Android
budget smartphone competition
specifically phones like the pixel 6A
for 450 dollars the iPhone se4 is going
to destroy and I'm going to explain why
in this video however there is going to
be some changes to the iPhone lineup in
terms of the pricing that is going to
cause the se4 to get a little bit more
expensive but I'll explain later on in
this video now getting into these leaks
you probably already know that last year
in December Ming shuko came out and said
that apple is Gonna Cancel or postpone
the 2024 iPhone se4 and my take was well
if they're gonna postpone it they're
probably just gonna cancel it anyway
because they have it on a two-year cycle
timeline as you know the iPhone SE 2
came out in April of 2020 and then
almost two years later in March of 2022
the se3 came out so it basically made
sense for the 2024 iPhone SC to come out
in the springtime and if it was going to
get delayed then there's no point it has
to come out in the spring of 2024 so I
figured they're just going to cancel it
and then guess what mishiko came back in
January and said apple is no longer
planning to launch it next year it is
officially canceled but no that wasn't
the end of the story there was more to
it make sure quote changed his mind and
it turns out that the iPhone SE 4 is
still coming next year but guess what it
is going to be even better than any of
us expected 6.1 inch OLED display with
Apple's 5G custom chip and that is
awesome because a couple of years ago
John Prosser leaked and revealed that
the iPhone se4 would use the iPhone 10rs
design and it totally makes sense
because Apple usually takes old designs
and gives them to the cheaper phones
like the SE so it was supposed to use
the 6.1 inch LCD iPhone 10r design but
it is getting even better this time
around not only is it getting a 6.1 inch
OLED display but it's actually going to
be a modification of the iPhone 14 that
we have right now with the new flat
sided redesign not the old design like
the iPhone 10r this is the new design
and even better it's probably going to
be the first iPhone ever to come with
Apple's custom baseband 5G chip and that
was actually confirmed by an executive
or the CEO of Qualcomm which makes the
current 5G chips that go into the
iPhones he says he expects Apple to use
their own 5G modem chips in
2024 and that likely means that it's
going to be the iPhone SE as the first
one and and why would Apple do this
instead of just giving the iPhone 16
lineup the more expensive phones the 5G
chip first well because apple is likely
going to save money with their own ship
compared to buying parts off the shelf
from Qualcomm which they up charge on
now I know the iPhone SE getting the
updated iPhone 14 design seems a little
bit unlikely because as you see right
now the current iPhone SE 3rd gen is
insanely old it has an LCD display
4.7 inch the rounded design it even has
the home button so why would Apple be as
crazy to literally give the iPhone se4
basically the same iPhone 14 design it's
gonna look almost exactly like this well
I believe it's because apple is on a
mission to charge you more money yes I
believe that the iPhone 15 lineup is
gonna get a little bit more expensive
across the board most likely on the Pro
Models at least a hundred dollar
difference and maybe on the regular
iPhone 15s I think it will and the
reason for that is because the iPhone 15
has actually leaked yes this is a leak
from unknowns 21 showing off the full
front design of the iPhone 15 and we can
instantly see the dynamic Island right
there at the top yes the notch is going
away so first of all yes the iPhone sc4
is going to have this design but it's
going to be notched while the iPhone 15
will no longer have a notch so that way
the iPhone SE 4 feels a little bit less
expensive and less premium compared to
the new ones but not only that we can
see right here that we have USBC which
probably will come on the iPhone se4 as
well but we see the rounded design we
have flat right here and then it curves
and matches the glass with 2.5 D glass
yeah shrimp Apple Pro confirmed that the
display on the iPhone 15 is still going
to be around 6.1 inches but because it's
rounded and the bezels are Getting
Thinner it's going to be true 6.1 inch
compared to the 6.06 on the iPhone 14.
so if you don't know what I'm talking
about we actually have exclusive cads of
the iPhone 15 release from Max Weinbach
and if you look closely right here you
can see that the bottom or the sides has
a flat design but then you can see that
curve come in compared to the iPhone 14
which does not have that curve so it's
going to be a newer design it's going to
feel more fresh and more premium while
the iPhone se4 sticks to this older
completely flat side design but guess
what the iPhone 15 Pro is going to be
even better with more features packed in
and new design changes that the iPhone
15 is not getting but before I get into
that I've got a talk about this the
magic stand case from our partner K SKU
which basically combines the best and
most Wanted aspects of a case into one
you've not only got a great and durable
design with stronger Max save magnets
built in but the max a freeing is
literally on a hinge so you could use it
as a finger grip or a 40 to 120 degree
stand and the best part is that it folds
back completely flush with the case so
it doesn't interfere with any of your
other Max save Chargers or accessories
so check out the link into all the
discount info in the video description
below and getting to the iPhone 15 Pro
this is going to be absolutely insane as
you can see we have a massive massive
camera bump with this new design and
USBC maybe even Thunderbolt And if you
look right here the camera bump is huge
it takes up a big part of the back of
the phone and the bump is self is almost
as thick as the actual phone which blows
my mind and as you can see right here we
are gonna have even thinner bezels than
we already have on the 14 pro this
design is gonna be insane not only that
but the iPhone 15 Pros a17 bionic chip
is going to bring Major Performance and
battery life gains on the 15 Pro lineup
due to the three nanometer process from
tsmc and not only that but Apple has
basically taken the entire initial
supply of three nanometer chips from
tsmc for their iPhones and M3 chip and
here's a crazy thing the a17 bionics
chip with three nanometer could be 35
more energy efficient leading to huge
battery life gains and I don't think
that's the end of it because I
personally think that three nanometer is
going to bring a new Core Design to both
the CPU and GPU probably including Ray
tracing for the GPU cores improved
efficiency in other features like
probably lower heat less display dimming
and 8K 60 video recording which I hope
is coming and we can't forget the
titanium finish which is going to be
exclusive to the 15 Pro Models I mean
this is going to look absolutely
incredible and we also have the new
button design on the 15 Pro where it's
actually going to have solid state
buttons yes just like the touch ID
button which didn't actually move or
this trackpad the four sets trackpad
which doesn't move at all yes those
Force touch buttons are coming to the 15
Pro Models only so because of that I
think apple is going to increase the
price of the 15 Pro Models which will
let them increase the price of the 15s a
little bit and then that leaves a huge
gap between the se3 right now and the
regular iPhone so I think that the
iPhone S e is gonna end up costing at
least five hundred dollars but because
of the feature set it is going to be an
absolute steal of a deal at least
compared to other Android phones
especially for the reliable iOS software
and the last piece of the puzzle is USBC
is the new se4 gonna get it well it is
going to be coming out in the spring of
2024 and technically Apple has until the
end of 2024 to have their iPhones use
lightning and the issue is that if they
release it with lightning in the spring
they're kind of gonna have to get rid of
it in the fall or the end of the year at
least in the EU so does Apple cancel it
in the EU force people to buy the
regular iPhone or do they just give it
the USBC Port right away I'm not sure
but one thing for certain is that apple
is planning mfi for USBC which is going
to limit your data speeds and charging
speeds in if you're using some crappy
third-party cable they're gonna force
you to buy the nice USBC mfi cables to
get the best features which is
unfortunate and shrimp Apple pro has
confirmed this but either way I think
the iPhone se4 is going to be a really
killer budget phone and I'm personally
really excited for it because the
previous design sucked with the touch ID
button the crappy 4.7 inch LCD display
and the new one with OLED and the new
flat sided design is going to be awesome
so let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe and definitely check out one
of those two videos right there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
foreign